أول شكل جديد من وسائل النقل
الجماعي منذ أن أحضر لنا الأخوان رايت
الطائرة الآن ، كانت
الساعة 12:02 صباحًا في الثاني عشر من مايو ، كانت في
الصحراء بالقرب من لاس فيجاس ،
وأنهى Hyperloop one أول
اختبار كامل لأنظمة هذا الاختبار الآن  كشف
لأول مرة خمسة أربعة ثلاثة اثنان واحد
حريق اختبار الخمس ثوان وكانت هناك
نتيجة ثلاث سنوات من العمل من قبل
كيفن فيش باوزر مؤسس
Hyperloop ونذكر مشاهدينا
لأولئك الذين هم على دراية بما هو مميز
حول طريقة سيارتك  يتحرك
عبر النفق تمامًا ، لذا فإن ما يتعين علينا
القيام به هو وجود فريق كان مؤسسي المشارك جوش
بعنوان حاسم في ذلك في قيادة
الهندسة كرئيس ، حيث كان التحليق هو ثلاثة
أشياء تخترع سمائنا
في الأنبوب ، لذا يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت
تطير  على ارتفاع مائتي ألف قدم
ونظام الدفع الذي
اخترعناه من نقطة الصفر ، لذا فهو يعمل الآن ،
عليك فقط أن تجعله على نطاق واسع
وتجد أن شخصًا ما سيدفع لك مقابل بناء
رحلة حقيقية كاملة النطاق  يعد el boat
بالتأكيد أول شكل رئيسي جديد
من وسائل النقل منذ مائة عام
، ولهذا السبب كان الأخوان رايت
مصدر إلهام لجوش وأنا
والفريق بأكمله ، حيث أن قدرتنا على إجراء هذا
الاختبار تثبت أننا قمنا ببنائه بالفعل.
يزن الهيكل
مليوني رطل ، وهو رابع أكبر
نظام فراغ في العالم أصبح صغيرًا
مقارنة بما يجب أن تقوم ببنائه
من لوس أنجلوس إلى سان فرانسيسكو أو
فيغاس إلى لوس أنجلوس ، وطريقتنا هي أن نكون
متكررين لإثبات أنه يعمل  إن
البنية التحتية العالمية التي تضع الذرات
والبتات معًا مكلفة للغاية ، فأنت بحاجة
إلى الحكومات لدعمك لبناء
هدفنا هو إظهار أن هذا يعمل على أن
Hyperloop حقيقي وأن Hyperloop One قد
فعل ما يقرب من
ثلاثمائة شخص يعملون بدوام كامل
على مدار الساعة  اجعل كل هذا يحدث